it's great to speak with you this
morning so listen the tagline of this
series is inexperience is an asset so
what's something in your life that
you've done that you had zero experience
doing but it turned out to be an asset
oh
mother becoming a mother nobody you
don't you don't have a clue what you're
doing and then all of a sudden that you
get handed a baby and then you're like
oh I'm gonna take care of this okay then
is it
what about you Noah
that's the best that's the best answer
I mean could be Pottery could be skiing
could be all the things
um personally I'm also with the
motherhood one I can relate Laura I can
relate
it's craziness right so listen Noah I
know that when you first read this
script it was it just resonated with you
and you were like who wrote this script
like who put me in this script what was
it about the character of Owen that was
just so similar to you
I'm really not this analytical I wish I
was I just read it and felt that I could
play it
um
I
I think his
maybe maybe it was like his his it was
so clear that he had insecurity that was
hidden with bravado
um I don't know if that's me but I just
felt like I could play that really well
um although I am like an insecure person
too at times
um
yeah I honestly I think it was just more
about how much I loved how Alexi wrote
him as a character
um he was quick he was witty he was
intelligent but he was inexperienced and
it wasn't like he wasn't capable of
doing his job it's just the fact that
he's still getting his bearings because
it's his second day on the job so I
think I just I loved that lens going
into the Spy genre
um as like a young kid out of college
who had just graduated it's their first
job and it just so happens that they're
working at the CIA
um
yeah I just was totally captivated by
that that's awesome I mean it's really
cool to see like a younger person in the
CIA because a lot of times I think we
see someone who's like a little more
older and like established so I really
love the take on this for sure uh Laura
um Russian accent can we just talk about
this for a second it blows my mind that
you were so incredible with this Russian
accent walk me through what the process
is to kind of like hone in on something
like that
you just become really obsessed with
watching and listening to women from
Russia and learning about
you know what these women have had to do
throughout their lives to survive and
how that informs
everything how that informs how they
communicate the tone of voice that they
use the melody at which they play with
with their voice there's no time for
like any sort of like sing-songy you
know ah let me just go over here and
think about this idea and then I'll pop
over here and think about this idea and
let me just Universe none of that is
just all very to the point very straight
structured so yeah I love it I love
working in accent and I think often if
I'm having to do something in my own
accent that's when I feel like that's
really challenging to me to find a
character that exists in my voice in my
tone so I loved working in I love
working with the Russian accent learning
Russians are difficult though oh my God
you've learned German for this didn't
you remember I memorized Germany you
memorized it
that is impressive I'm like super
impressed with y'all very impressed uh
you don't want to hear my Russians
learning a new language as an adult is
so difficult because the my kids came
with me to Montreal when we were filming
and we were there for five months six
months and they picked up French and
they were like you know going into
little stores in Montreal and chatting
in French to the to the people behind
the counters and I'm like watching them
and they're just sponges and just
incredible absorbing it and they
especially my little girl just using her
French but then mommy's at home like
come on
days and days
Russia that's great we could all use
learn a little thing from like our
little ones right they're so incredible
and so resilient so I wish I could learn
that quick well thank you both so much
um congratulations on this series it's
awesome it's awesome and I'm really
excited for the world to see it thank
you thank you take care